for somebody
who studied war who participated in war
what do you think is the best martial
arts
for um let's call it self-defense
for hand-to-hand combat outside
the constraints of sport so
it's not one answer the answer to me is
jiu-jitsu boxing wrestling
muay thai judo
[ __ ] and on down the list i definitely
start with
jiu jitsu the reason i start with jiu
jitsu is because in a self-defense
situation
you are a big monster human and you want
to fight me
and you square off with me guess what
i'm going to do
run away because i don't want i don't
want to get involved
even if i see skinny little lex
out on the street and you start yelling
at me and saying you want to fight me i
don't want to fight you
i don't it doesn't matter i don't care
if i can beat you or not what if you
stab me
what if you sue me after i get done
throwing you onto the concrete
there's a million bad things that can
happen and almost nothing good
so for self-defense my first
self-defense is my feet to get away from
you
and if you square off to punch me i can
run away from you if you square off to
kick me i can run away from you
if you push me i can run away from you
so
great i don't need to know how to box to
run away from you
where this all changes is when you grab
me
and now i don't have the option to run
away anymore now i actually have to know
how to get away from your grip
and that's where jiu jitsu comes into
play so
especially if you get me on the ground
if you if you grab me and
get me on the ground now i need to know
how to get you off of me and get up and
get away from you so i can run away
so that's why i say start with jiu jitsu
and and from there
boxing wrestling judo [ __ ]
muay thai yeah there's uh there's cert
in the standing position
i mean i'm a judo person as well and
the judo is very limited in their
understanding of the full grappling
spectrum
even though they do all the things on
the ground as well but
uh it's so focused on the feet but
nevertheless
it's important to understand the thing
that
judo has as a sport
that's good to practice that jiu jitsu
doesn't
is uh not just the
gra the skill of grappling on the feet
but the skill of
explosive aggression that
sometimes jiu jitsu is more about in
terms of tactics is more about patience
and it depends how you practice it but
because so much is
uh about control and technique
that uh sometimes you don't get to
practice like aggression
explosive aggression and judo is so much
about
uh aggression implemented in such a way
that the
demonstration of power is effortless
right that's the beauty of jiu-jitsu
yeah and same thing with wrestling
wrestling also has a high level of
intensity and aggression as well yes
yeah so that's where that's where i
agree judo and wrestling
absolutely awesome get some
and striking boxing muay thai yeah you
know like
the you should train all these things
you